Zootopia tells the tale of a young bunny
named Judy Hopps who really dreams of
being a police officer this is not
something that's common in fact if she
were to become an officer she would be
the very first rabbit to ever do it and
she does and when she gets on a case
that involves some missing mammals in
Zootopia a place where predators and
prey all get along she teams up with a
Sly Fox named Nick Wilde to help solve
the case the trailers for Zootopia are
marketing it as a fun cute movie for
kids that has the little animal people
in it I was legitimately floored
throughout this movie this movie is
fantastic this is so much deeper and so
much more mature than I expected it to
be this is a fully realized well-rounded
film this isn't just a fun little movie
the kids can enjoy that's passable this
is actually an extremely layered movie
with far more to say than I ever
anticipated and it's also relentlessly
entertaining it is so much fun this is a
very enjoyable movie that is actually
more focused on its story than making
you laugh and that's something I loved
about it watching Zootopia it genuinely
felt like a movie made for adults just
with bunnies and foxes and rhinos and
lions and if this reaction is surprising
you right now trust me the movie itself
surprised me this movie is extremely
emotional it has a lot to say about
racial stereotypes about gender
stereotypes about friendships
relationships drugs
seriously this who it's a lot deeper
than I thought it was gonna be but it
didn't feel heavy-handed it felt
important it felt necessary it felt very
timely and it was also just extremely
entertaining and fun these two lead
characters Judy Hopps and Nick Wilde so
great I love these characters I want to
see more of these characters Jennifer
Goodwin was great as Judy Hopps Jason
Bateman was fantastic as Nick Wilde I
love the voice work in this movie I
loved address Elba as the cliched angry
chief really great stuff he was such a
cool character the only issues I have
with this movie are an opening
exposition dump that just pours all this
information on you you need to know that
you don't really need to know but it's
sort of like they were letting the kids
know information that you need to have a
sort of awareness of but then eventually
the real movie starts almost like they
were like hey kids this is gonna be fun
here's all this
oh by the way his movies actually about
racism and drugs and the other small
nitpick that I had was right between act
2 and 3 there's a lull there it's not
bad it's just kind of like all right I
know the plots going to kick in here so
let's go and then it goes and it's just
like it's great music by Michael
Giacchino who seems to be doing every
great score ever nowadays was also
amazing the action sequences were also
terrific we have well realized
characters
well realized action a great score great
animation and a good message this movie
is awesome
Zootopia gets an A don't miss this one
this is a movie not just for kids but
also for adults in fact I can actually
see adults enjoying this movie even more
possibly guys thank you so much as
always for watching I greatly appreciate
it look forward to this Sunday my retro
rewind of Superman 64
I'm actually going to sit down and try
to play it and I'll I'll film it
Sunday guys thank you so much as always
for watching if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes